Allah subhanahaala
tells us in the next verses of
we have the description of a man
that was one of the lead antagonists of
our prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
and his name was Alwi Mira. Alw was
extremely wealthy. He was a very high
ranking chieftain. He was considered the
most wealthy man in Quraysh in Mecca in
his time. And not only that, but he had
some good qualities before Islam during
the days of Jahyah. He was very just. He
was very generous
and he also had some ideals that
reflected the true fra of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. for instance,
he was known to have never drank, never
dro never touched a drop of alcohol and
viewed it as something that was
deplorable, something that honorable
people didn't engage in and didn't do.
, and so he took care of the Kaa. He
was one of the main contributors
to the reconstruction of the Kaa.
Not only that, but he used to cloak the
Kaa and take care of the people that
came to Hajj every single year. And so
was not a monster. He wasn't a terrible
evil villain. He was considered to be
the best of the best of people before
Islam. So much so that he anticipated
that he was going to be the prophet.
Yes. He thought he was going to be the
prophet. Could you imagine somebody
being so into themselves,
so much hubris that they
start to think that they are competing
with the messenger of Allah sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. This is very near
insanity, right? And there were many
you know more than a a few people
when the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
was appointed by Allah as a messenger
who fancied themselves more rightful to
being a prophet than he was. And Muira
had a lot of he had his fingers in a lot
of pies as they say and he was an
integral part of the Meccan society
preIslnamic Meccan society and he felt
that he should have been the prophet
instead of the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions this
in
he mentions this in
they said that if you are truly a
prophet why didn't Allah send down the
Quran to someone who's more rightful
to prophethood than you are and this is
What Allah mentioned in
this was one of their arguments. Who
were these people that they viewed were
more rightful? Wellbi
also from and
from Mecca. He's the father of
these were the nobility of Mecca. And so
last night we discussed the the the
ramifications of this and we mentioned a
litmus test that we're supposed to test
ourselves. How much of my ideas? How
much of your ideas? How much of your
opinions are actually your opinions?
Would you have survived the propaganda
machine of the mushri of Quraysh if you
were around during that time? If you
were around during that time and you
grew up looking up to people Abu
Jah and looking up to people like
Abuahab and looking up to people Mu
and looking up to people Ib and
people like
Khalif and Ib and others and they all
collectively unite and turn against
[Arabic recitation]
Would you have survived that propaganda?
Would you have jumped on their
bandwagon? Or do you have the strength
of mind and strength of character to
think for yourself? To think for
yourself and to question authority. You
grew up in Mecca looking up to these
people. And these people now
all point their finger unanimously and
say that he is a liar, he is a madman,
he is a poet, he is sick, he is a
magician. Would you have survived it?
It's the equivalent of today
of all of the major news organizations
turning against a person. If CNN and BBC
and El Jazzer and Elam and NBC and C
NBC, MSNBC and all of these groups and
Twitter and Instagram and whatever else,
if all of these liars would have gotten
together and collaborated
in telling every person and going out of
their way to say, "This man is a liar.
This man is a magician. This man is and
pointing out the faults of every one of
his followers. Look at the kind of
people that are following him, right?
People Ali, he's just a little boy
or she's just a woman, right? orbel
this loner, you know, Christian that,
you know, for all intents and purposes,
I mean, he's intelligent, but he's an
old decrepit man who can't even see
anymore, right? His followers are a
bunch of slaves
and
would you have survived it? Would you
survive that today? What makes you
angry? Where do you get your anger from?
Do you get it from the book of Allah and
the sunnah of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam or do you get it from Al
Jazz on NBC? Where do you get it from?
This is something that you have to ask
yourself
because
the easiest thing to consolidate power
is people's outrage and anger. Think
about the last major cause you were
outraged about. Where did you get that
from? Whether domestic or international.
If I say to you right now, who is the
worst man to live in the past 100 years?
Who just came into your mind? Not what
you would say. I'm asking who just
popped into your mind right now. What
name? What character? What villain?
Where did you get that from? Who taught
you that?
Right? These are the questions that we
have to ask ourselves because propaganda
is one of the strongest tools that a
shan uses. Until today, every day the
prophet sallall.aii
said,
he said, "Whomever Allah desires good
for,
he will give him enemies from amongst
humanity. He will turn people against
him." Not good people, bad people, not
people of knowledge, people of
ignorance.
He will have enemies that will
antagonize him. Why?
Because an enemy is more beneficial to a
hero
than a friend.
The prophets and messengers,
they were all promised an enemy. But not
all of them had friends. Not all of them
had followers.
Some of them will come on the day of
judgment having no one accepted their
da'wah.
However, every one of them has an enemy
as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said. Why?
because
things only come
full circle and are clear in their
entirety when their opposite is
introduced. We only appreciate sun
sunshine because of rainy days. We only
appreciate comfort because of
discomfort. We only appreciate day
because of night. And we only
understanded because of our
understanding of shik and superstition.
We only appreciate and understand fully
the prophets and messengers because we
are introduced to their opposites and
their opposition.
And so this question of who thinks for
you, we're not speaking about taking and
trusting the opinion of people who are
trustworthy and
and qualified. That's not what we're
speaking about. So for instance, when I
get on a plane, I trust the pilot. I
trust the pilot. I trust thee. Does this
mean I don't think for myself? No. I
have to trust this person. But when we
say, "Do you think for yourself?"
Do you get your outrage and your love
and hate and friend and foe from the
Quran or do you get it from elsewhere?
What we mean by this is something that
you are able to think for yourself for
yet in spite of that you allow someone
else to do it for you. You hand over
your free will and your intellect and
you allow someone else to use you as a
vessel for his or her ideologies or
opinions. How many of your enemies are
not really your personal enemies?
They're the enemies of your friends.
They were people that you were told to
dislike.
How many of your friends are not people
that you particularly but you were
told to them? You were told to
accept them. This was the
scene in the time of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam in Mecca. Now when
we look at
those first verses that were revealed in
surah regarding him Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala then speaks about a very specific
incident
that occurred with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us of
the moment he chose to go to the
hellfire.
Allah tells us about the moment he chose
to go to hell and to reject the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam and it wasn't
because he truly believed that he was
not a prophet that's not why Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said
for
[Silence]
these verses were revealed regarding the
moment
when the propaganda machine of the
Mushrien
started and began to
rumble and began to steamroll over
the salvation of the people of Mecca and
their followers.
Inb
tells us that once the prophet sallam
was reciting the Quran to some people in
Mecca and one of those people was
he sat and he listened to the Quran.
He listened to it being recited and he
was so mesmerized,
so captivated,
so enthralled by the Quran and its
verses.
So much so that the people of Mecca
started to whisper that Ali
is going to become Muslim
and Abu Jah couldn't have that. And it
was true. He was very near to accepting
Islam.
And so Abu Jahel, Abu Jahel is Alwi Mu's
nephew.
So Abu Jahel, his uncle is Ali Mu.
He said, "Guys, don't worry about it.
Let me take care of my uncle. I'll deal
with it."
So he went to his uncle
and his uncle was a very proud man. He
was very proud of his riches. We said he
was the most wealthy person in Mecca,
right? And that was a s that wasn't just
a source of pride for him. That was his
identity. He was the rich man, the
wealthy man. And that's what that's what
really gave him his identity and and
sense of selfworth.
So Abu Jahi knew exactly which button to
push. He came to
and he said
uncle I am you know he he expressed that
he wasn't feeling very good. He had
something on his mind. And so Elw said
you know what's what's going on nephew?
He said in in so many words, obviously
I'm paraphrasing. He said,
"The people of Mecca, you know, the
chieftains, , we were just talking and
we are thinking about pulling some money
together to give you a stipend because
you've gotten so old and you seem to be
in need of money."
And so W immediately said,
He said knows that I am the most wealthy
man amongst them. What do you mean give
me money? You're going to pull money
together. He said, "Yeah, you know,
they're saying you're so old now." Of
course, he was in his 80s when this took
place because
died at the ripe old age of 95 years
old, 3 months after hijah. So he was in
his 80s when the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was appointed a prophet
and messenger. So he said, "Yeah,
they're saying that you're old now. You
can't get around as you used to. They
want to pull pull some money together
and you know take care of you." He
said, "How dare you even suggest such a
thing? Why are they saying that?" He
said, 'Well, you know, some people saw
you sit in with Muhammad, and it seems
they think you're being attracted
to him because of some money that you'll
get from him.
And he said, "Absolutely not."
And so Abu Jahan said, "Listen,
well to clear this up, you should really
say something absolute regarding
Muhammad and cut all your ties with him
100%.
State your position in no uncertain
terms so that people, you know, will
stop with these rumors."
And so this is the incident when that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala speaks about
in these verses regarding
and the propaganda that he started to
turn out and he started to coordinate
with the other chieftains of Mecca
especially during Hajj season. We will
discuss that tomorrow night inshallah.
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu
Allah Subhanahua
Alhamdulillah.